Speaker 1: Yesterday, we saw closing statements
in the Derek Shervin trial in Minnesota.
This is the trial of the police officer who
killed George Floyd in the case that last
summer catalyzed nationwide protests.
We may soon know the verdict, but in the meantime,
it's even conceivable by the time we published
this clip, we will know the verdict, although
it doesn't seem to be moving quite so quickly.
But in the meantime, what we know for sure
is that Derek Chauvin's lawyer, Eric Nelson,
gave a completely deranged and delusional
closing statement that in a sense actually
felt trumping in the way that Trump pushed
the presidency to new lows.
Eric Nelson pushed legal defense to new lows
with this ridiculous closing statement.
Here is Eric Nelson saying that there are
elements of criminal trials that are like
chocolate chip cookies.
Yes, take a look
Speaker 2: at the criminal case is kind of
like baking chocolate chip cookies.
You have to have the necessary ingredients.
You've got to have flour and sugar and butter
and chocolate chips and whatever else goes
into those chocolate chip cookies.
If you have all of the ingredients, you can
make chocolate chip cookies.
But if you're missing any one single ingredient,
you can't make chocolate chip cookies.
It's a simple kind of analogy, but the criminal
law works the same way.
We say the inaccurately called the ingredients,
the elements.
The state has the burden of proving each and
every element beyond a reasonable doubt.
Speaker 1: Not only is it bizarre, it's also
wrong.
Like you can make chocolate chip cookies,
often without any one ingredient.
You might think, well, I definitely need flour.
No, you can use flour alternatives.
Well, OK, but I need eggs now.
You can use applesauce as an emulsifier instead
of eggs.
OK, but butter, I definitely need no.
You can replace butter with any number of
lubricating elements, oils of different kinds.
It's just a very dumb analogy.
But sadly, it may be one that is fine tuned
to what Eric Nelson perceives to be the level
of the jury.
We just don't know.
That's the scary part.
This may actually work.
I've talked before about my jury duty experience
on an assault case, and the most infuriating
part was nobody would want to say nobody,
almost no one in the jury room even understood
what it was we were adjudicating.
It was a question of was a physical altercation,
self-defense by the accused and by self-defense,
we don't mean, you know, backyard bar rules
of what constitutes self-defense.
We were supposed to adjudicate this case on
the basis of the judge's instructions as to
what legally self-defense is.
Did it meet the required legal elements for
self-defense?
And the conversation in the jury room among
everybody other than myself and one other
juror was a colloquial discussion of, now,
come on, this was self-defense.
Well, but hold on a second.
At the time I lived in Massachusetts, what
is Massachusetts law about a right to retreat?
What anyway, the point was on something that
simple, two thirds of the jurors didn't even
understand the law meant to be adjudicated.
I'm not hugely optimistic about any particular
jury.
I know nothing about the Derek Shoven case
But based on my experience, I'm skeptical.
Here's another portion of the closing where
Erik Nelson says if you were talking, you
were breathing.
Therefore, since George Floyd was saying,
I can't breathe, it means his breathing is
fine, which has already been debunked by Dr.
Martin Tobin, a pulmonologist who testified
during the case.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: It's true.
If you are talking, you are breathing.
Doesn't mean effectively.
And Dr. Tobin described how even medical doctors
have problems, sometimes assessing the legitimacy
of a patient's needs relevant to their respiratory
processes because they're saying, I can't
breathe and some doctors confuse it for just
anxiety or this or that.
So if medical doctors make these mistakes,
Dr. Tobin told you, it provides a false sense
of security, right?
Lieutenant Mursal told you that that is what
is said among police officers.
He's the trainer.
So how many times we hear an officer say,
based on his training and experience, if you
can breathe, you can talk, you can talk, you
can breathe.
Speaker 1: And then Nelson goes directly from
this into the claim that.
Very often people in custody will fake a medical
emergency to avoid going to prison.
Now, this seems particularly bogus since George
Floyd really did die, is the argument that
because other people have faked medical emergencies,
Derek Chauvin did nothing wrong in his handling
of Floyd?
I think that's what he's trying to imply.
At least take a look at this video.
Speaker 2: A reasonable police officer will
take into consideration again, his training,
his experience.
Right.
Lieutenant Mursal talked about and many people
talked about, many of the officers talked
about how it is not uncommon for suspects
to feign or pretend to have a medical emergency
to avoid being harassed.
Unfortunately, that is the reality.
Nobody likes to get arrested and reasonable
police officers know that.
Speaker 1: You know, these hypotheticals for
me aren't doing much, but it's possible that
they're doing something for the jury.
We just don't know yet.
And then lastly, here is Derek Chauvin's attorney,
Erik Nelson, saying, listen, Derek Chauvin
could have kicked George Floyd, he could have
punched George Floyd, he could have elbowed
George Floyd, but he didn't almost like the
argument is he deserves an award because he
didn't kill and elbow George Floyd.
He merely killed him.
And I guess that's to be looked up at to take
a look
Speaker 2: at Officer Sherman made a decision
not to use higher levels of force when he
would have been authorized to do that, including
punches, kicks, elbows.
Right.
All of these tools were available to officer
show that is not an intent to purposefully
use unlawful force.
Speaker 1: All right.
And then actually, that very last one here
is Eric Nelson saying, listen, George Floyd
being put face down, that can't be a problem
because people do really nice things face
down.
Sometimes people sleep face down, sometimes
people suntanned face down.
So therefore, being face down can't possibly
be part of this case.
Speaker 2: We've heard a lot about the prone
position.
Consider just the basic proposition.
People sleep in the proposition, people suntanned
in the prime position.
People give massages in the prone position.
The proposition in and of itself is not an
inherently dangerous act.
It is not an inherently dangerous act.
Speaker 1: So this is the idea and this is
a common legal strategy.
Take each piece and say that's not a problem
prone position, isn't a problem by itself.
Knee to the neck isn't a problem by itself.
A plus.
You know, Derek Shervin didn't punch George
Floyd, he didn't elbow George Floyd.
But the point is all together, it is a big
deal.
Everything together killed George Floyd, period.
And that is what is ultimately being adjudicated
here.
I really couldn't tell you how this is going
to end up.
We're left to wait.
There is tension in Minnesota in advance of
the verdict, concerns about unrest.
And to be clear, Derek Chauvin is innocent
until proven guilty.
Don't send me the voice mails about.
Oh, David, you're looking to hang this guy.
First of all, I'm against the death penalty.
I'm not looking to hang anybody.
And of course, Derek Chauvin is innocent until
proven guilty.
He deserves competent defense counsel like
everyone else.
Full stop.
There's no qualifier.
The closing statement just happens to be nonsense,
but that doesn't mean it will not work.
Maybe Erik Nelson is a moron, but maybe Erik
Nelson accurately has assessed what will appeal
to this jury.
And that may be the chocolate chip cookie
analogy.
We will know when we get the verdict.
Let me know what you expect.
You can find me on Twitter at
David Pakman.